her car's pulled up in front all the
windows started coming through bam bam
all the guns are out i'm seeing old bill
standing everywhere next thing
the windows have all busted in
all the windows have come through i mean
i've been pulled out the back window of
the car
[Music]
the first time i ever went to prison was
for a big police chase all around
central london park lane marla burn
crashed into a police car side planet
and green police station
carried on going went up park laying the
wrong way
had police cars crash into me there
stung my tires out and that was my first
my first prison sentence going through
the prison system it just made me bitter
it made me feel like i could just do
whatever i like and commit crime as and
well and as i'm well i fit if i want it
i'm taking it and no one could do it or
say anything about it and that's exactly
how
my attitude was and what i would do is
just walk walk around the streets of
london literally and i would look at
things in cars and i would smash the
windows and i'd take the phones or the
laptops and it was literally walking the
pavements of london every day all day
every day just trying to find something
to steal
so i could sell it so i could get a bit
of money so i could get food you know i
went from being a small-time criminal to
progressing to progressing so you could
just imagine as you start off small and
you progress you become you start
training your skills and
i've done that for i did that for years
uh becoming a criminal and just
basically bit by bit going through the
criminal world
going bigger going bigger going bigger i
don't know why the criminal people look
at i think bank robbers are the best
thing but they do unfortunately
um me and nick my co-defendant we
decided well we suppose how can we rob
this place how can we rob a bank on
broad daylight
without any weapons without any one
questioning us
so before well
burke's burgers is the best way because
you're completely covered from head to
toe you can't see your face
you can wear gloves and you can blend
into any situation like you're in london
streets and it only takes a second to
pull that disguise off and you're back
in civilian clothes
so we've gone to regent's park mosque
and i've gone into the clothing section
and there was a load of muslim women in
there as well as everybody else and i'm
trying on these dresses me and nick are
trying them on and i'm looking at nick
nick's looking at me he's like yeah you
look good i'm like yeah you look good
instead of taking them off
and then walking out the shop and paying
for them like we do normally
nick's like can we wear him and i've
looked at him i was like really he's
like yeah let's wear them it'll be fun
this is where our mentality this is
where i understand we was not
thinking correctly
um
we're just in it for the for the glory i
think that's what it was i paid 80
pounds for my dress nick paid 80 pound
for his dress
and then we've left the with leicester
mosque
um as we're walking out
um the security guards obviously seen
the two of us with big big built men
we've got big shoulders we've got big
arms and we don't look like women plus
we're dressed in burkas
so the shape of our body giving us a way
straight away plus our height so he's
come he's seen us both of us obviously
he's gone for the smaller one which
would be me um as he's come to me
obviously my whole thing is i can't let
him detain me so i've just dealt with
him as quick as i could put him on his
ass and and got out there but because of
that because i've just dropped this guy
and he's now screaming his head off
for the whole all the people to see
next thing like literally i would say at
least 150 people started chasing me and
my buddy nick um so i'm running him in
the burka trying to get my keys out my
pocket nick's run off that way he's
getting chased by a load of people i'm
running jumped in my car shaking like a
leaf because i've got all these people
chasing me i've locked the door put the
key in the ignition and as i'm tearing
off literally people are jumping on the
car pulling bits off mirrors are coming
off windscreens and wipers are coming
off
and then i'm gone but then obviously
i've gone around the corner to my mates
house uh who lives in the green listen
green estate
and then uh from there we just we
decided right let's go let's let's do
this thinking back we didn't think that
that situation
would even
affect our path that's how naive i would
say we were we've met up we're like you
ready we're like yep sweet so then we've
gone to kilburn high road and that's
when we've robbed the bank literally
about
an hour later we're in the banking for
you we're waiting for the guy to go
and um and it was just by luck for us
that day there was uh there was a couple
of muslim people actually in the bank
genuine muslim ladies
and they were fully dressed in burkas as
well
so we've sort of blended into these this
little crowd of people yeah
so we're in the bank and we're moving
forward with the queue um and the next
thing um the security guard that's
carrying the money to and from the bank
is right beside me now and right beside
the shoot is where he puts the money in
and then it's on a safe that turns
within the banking area so he's putting
the money in there
but what happens normally is they'll
come in with the box
he opens the box up takes the bag of
cash out which was 25 000 pound
holds it in his hand and scans it with
had handheld terminal finger as he's
done that he puts the money into the
safe
as he's done that i've grabbed him and i
flung him across the bank
not in no weapons nothing nothing major
because we were only young we never ever
had intentions of hurting anyone that's
exactly we was not there to hurt people
we were one there for the glory because
we wanted to hit the papers being
dressed in burkas robbing banks that's
what we was like we were freaking
stupid kids i've thrown in my mates
grabbed their cash and then we've run
out the bank
jumped in the car the getaway car which
was parked right outside the bank and
then we've gone
um crashed the car a few miles away and
i end up crashing the car
and then we've run through a park i've
end up putting taking the dress off
i put the dress in the bin in one of
them dog bins
and then the police obviously they found
that they found my dna on that they've
got the picture from the mosque so i was
just done i was guilty as hell i
couldn't couldn't get out of it so i
played guilty straight away
got um i ended up getting three years
for that
did it give you a sort of status in
prison yeah it did yeah yeah especially
when i've seen all the stuff in the
newspaper i've come out of prison
and i had um
i had the mentality that i was
untouchable i thought i was i generally
thought i was
i thought i was better than the police
and
my lifestyle then became
more erratic more i was full of hate i
hated it like i hated the police i hated
the world that i lived in i hated
everyone i literally generally hated
everybody at that precise time in my
life i'd um
i'd broken up with my partner who i was
with for 10 years i had three kids with
her
um and the relationship was was not good
um
obviously i was taking alcohol i was
taking drugs at that time in my life
because
that was the lifestyle unfortunately
someone else had then informed me that
they know where
um
they know where a property the property
developer lives that has large
quantities of jewelry in their house so
we've gone we've traveled to radler
hertfordshire and i sat outside this
house for
four or five hours waiting for this
person to come back the lady's come back
she's pulled up her big metal gates have
opened up at the front of her house the
big gates have closed behind her she's
driving a
silver mercedes convertible mercedes
into the house and i was
i was just concentrating on the money i
wasn't caring about the victim i wasn't
thinking about how i was going to make
her feel or the effects that i would
have on her life
after we have just robbed her i didn't
think about that all i thought about was
i just want to get it over and done with
it as soon as possible get what we need
to do sell that get the money and then i
can i can worry about what i'm going to
do another couple of days down the line
once the money's gone
that's that's that was my attitude
what's happened to her is she's been put
on the floor
and all her jewelry was removed i fed
there and then on the spot watches rings
bracelets necklaces earrings and stuff
like that which is bad mate and i hate
even talking about this now we need to
go into her house and cut open the safe
and get there get the jewelry out the
safe because that's what we're there for
we're not there for what's on her we're
on we're there for what's in the safe
but because we're going to the safe
we're going to take everything off her
as well because it just makes sense
in for a penny in for a pound
and so
we've we've robbed this lady
um and i remember the
her face was well i can't explain it it
was horrible
she
she petrified me and
it made me feel sick
it just i just i i thought now mate so
i've run i left the building i've
grabbed my lads and we've run
i've run got in the car
drove off um
next thing
a big whack has come from the left-hand
side of the car
i think it was the left
yeah now yeah it was the left-hand side
a big smashing from the left-hand side
and i've looked
and all i can see is guys jumping out of
cars pulling out guns and putting caps
on and obviously i knew straight away i
was flying towards the police
so i've screamed at my drive at the
driver and go is this old bill this old
bill next thing enough of police cars
crashed into the side of this car the
cars pulled up in front all the windows
started coming through bam bam all the
guns were out i'm seeing old bill
standing everywhere pointing machine um
hand guns at me
next thing
the windows have all busted in all the
windows have come through i mean i've
been pulled out the back window in the
car
right and
we got hiding for it like literally we
got to beat him but rightly so we just
robbed the lady we needed a beating and
and we did and we got it we got what we
deserved we get rested
we go to the police station
uh i get taken to colindale police
station um i'm in prison
and we start getting all our case papers
our depths record all our paperwork
starts coming through and in the
paperwork it's got a thing called an
impact statement
now this this impact statement is the
impact of your offense that what the
offence you've committed on that person
the impact of that crime she then tells
or he sells
what what the impact is on them and in
her statement um
she explained how she felt she felt
afraid obviously she felt
i think she felt but what changed me and
changed my whole outlook on crime and
outlook on absolutely everything was the
fact that when she was being robbed she
got turned over
she got turned over so we could control
her but she at that point she thought
she was going to be raped
which
makes me feel disgusting mate because
i've been raped i've been raped loads
i had uh
parents that um
were quiet see my mum was good my
stepdad weren't so good
my my real dad he was terrible he slit
his throat when i was one
um in front of me and my brother
yeah then
a few years passed my mother
left my dad
left my father
and then
my mum met my stepdad he became abusive
and aggressive and used to beat my mum
all the time my mum left me with a
babysitter
whilst she left me with a babysitter the
babysitter raped me
um
basically the person that raped me was a
red boy and he was 14 years old
and uh
my mum used to um let this boy babysit
me
um after that
i became very angry very
very very um
dysfunctional as a child
i got to the age of about
four or five years of age and
my behavior was so unstable and i was
such a danger to myself
and others around me
they um
they put me in these
traumatized place for children for young
kids kids that suffer from sexual abuse
and trauma
and my behavior would deteriorate there
and i would be restrained
held down by members of staff mainly
four men normally
so i'd have two men holding me down at
the top two men holding my legs down
um and i'd be in a white padded room
there was white padded it was like a
safety room for damaged children should
we say
um
i got to the age of about six years old
and
and then what happened was
social services because i've been going
through the system now for three years
from the age of three up until the age
of six
uh everything they tried with me failed
so what they did decide to do was then
put me into care
and they put me in a place called the
marby bush in oxfordshire
and that is for trauma um young
traumatized kids got kicked out and i
went to a place called fort shirlen road
in central london
um and that is where i was there for
probably no more than two weeks and then
i got sent to another place up in kent
the worst thing about being in kent
was i met a kid
um he
introduced me to some other guy
and
i thought this excuse was my friend
i was only nine at the time
um and they've ended up taking me away
and then they both raped me in the field
they'd done that and the thing is i
never told anyone about this i never
told no one because
one i was so ashamed about what happened
to me too i was i didn't think anyone
would believe me
at this stage in my life my mother
wasn't
she didn't like me i don't think that
she liked me she i just i can't
understand her thinking behind it but
mine and her relationship was so bad at
this stage
that i would go to her house and she
wouldn't let me in this was going on for
so long my little sister my little
sister kelly would bring me out blankets
cigarettes and food and leave it on the
balcony for me and i and i did that for
a long time
did you feel like people were making an
effort to understand why you were
running away definitely not
definitely not and that's where it goes
wrong in a system like you've got so
many young kids that are mentally like
they're damaged kids mate i was a very
damaged child i experienced so much bad
stuff in my early life
that it made me completely different to
everyone else
and i didn't even know how to fix that a
lot of the children's homes there's a
lot of abuse that goes on in these
places like a lot
and this is what the public don't hear
about like there's a lot of kids
abusive towards each other
um so you've got a lot of sexual abuse
going on in them places you've got a lot
of um bullying going on in them places
and it's just not a nice place to be i'm
not saying all of them places are like
that but every single one that i've
experienced has um so then i've come out
of care absolutely clueless i don't know
how to read i don't know how to write i
don't know how to pay bills i don't know
how to drive properly i can drive
because i've known how to steal cars but
i don't know how to apply for a job and
social services never gave me anything
like that they never taught me how to
read they never taught me how to write
they never taught me how to manage money
management
because i was lacking all of them skills
the only thing i could
put my hands to was was crime i never
woke up decided that i want to be a thug
today
it was a lifestyle that was pushed upon
me you know i mean and that's not an
excuse it's just the way it was
i was always
hunting for something that i didn't know
what existed
and that a lot is love and i mean and
having a family unit having a wife
having the kids having a reason to be a
good dad and making sure that whatever
you
put into your kids heads it's good
if you deal with these things on a daily
basis love respect and just be decent
things are better things are better for
everybody man and it's not just you that
is going to benefit that the people
around you are going to benefit from
that being out of prison now um
my now i'm training now to be a
therapist which is to help kids or
people anyone that has been through
trauma so that's my journey now and to
help people that have been through what
i've been through
and all i do now is i
i talk to everybody and i encourage
everyone to talk because talking is a
massive thing it's important for me to
help people
especially people that have suffered
like i have it's very difficult for men
to talk
men do not talk about their feelings
this is one thing that needs to change
it's it's not macho for a man to be
there talking about his feelings if
you've got things that have been
haunting you for 30 years you need to
talk about it
did you ever meet the woman who had the
impact on you no i haven't but every
single podcast will go when i say sorry
like i say sorry on these ones i'd do it
more because i hope to meet her one day
i hope to meet her i hope to her hold
her hand and say sorry if she does ever
watch these things she'll see
that there's there's a genuine man in
front of the camera that he is sorry for
the things he's done you know he
generally is and he's he's trying to
make
make the world better now
[Music]
we lived on the third floor of a block
of flats and when the nazi party
came around collecting all the jews my
aunt who stayed with us looked out and
saw what was going on she couldn't do
anything about my mother who by that
time was taken downstairs into the
courtyard where they gathered all the
jewish women